my name is Detective Chief Inspector max
Berlin we will kill a hostage if our
demands are not met you can't give them
what they want I'll tell you that much
it's down to the negocio just to break
the deadlock or your men will have to
storm the embassy to authorities face
terrorism with negotiation or force the
Army's next door
it's the SAS still one shot they go me
we better make sure no one is we know
there are some hostages on the second
floor you tell your government one more
day we begin shooting them
an immediate assault plan has been
thrown up it's no get it's got the heart
of a lion in the brains about lunch
their army is going to attack us we can
hear them in the hall I want this to be
resolved peacefully keep sodium talking
during the assault you over to help kill
them I want you to save the hostages the
Prime Minister wants the world and the
British people to see how this
government deals with terrorism stand by
you and I can stop violence don't go go
[Music]
you